the thunderstorm rolled into sports
authority field before the Denver
Broncos game yesterday the four-person
parachute team gets fans excited ahead
of every football game their aerial
acrobatics make the thunderstorm one of
the most exciting pregame rituals in
professional sports it's the only one of
its kind in the NFL Dana Jacobson met
the Daredevils and suited up herself to
experience what makes the stunt so
dangerous and invigorate vigor aiding
Dana I'm so impressed good morning I'm
here so it went well a good morning a
few years ago the Denver Broncos decided
they wanted to upgrade their pregame
festivities they wanted something high
energy high speed and high drama now
minutes before kick-off from a plane
circling overhead the four members of
Denver's very own parachute team take
flight
from a sea of darkness they appear 5,000
feet over downtown Denver streaking
across the night sky before igniting
more than 70,000 fans packed into Sports
Authority Field at Mile House they are
the thunder storm swooping into the
stadium through a maze of Criss crossing
wires at 60 miles per hour to kick-off
Denver Broncos home base
[Applause]
[Applause]
the team trains an hour north at mile
high skydiving where the average sky
diver descends with a parachute twice as
big and lands at a speed three times
slower than the thunderstorm and what is
it about skydiving it's total freedom
you don't worry about you got bills to
pay
it's like 60 seconds to do your job and
then back to reality co-founder Jimmy
Trainor never considered doing anything
else even after losing his mother in a
skydiving accident as a kid even in the
darkest moments it was never a question
to me I just it was a matter of how old
I had to be before I could jump
something you love that couldn't imagine
not doing it they loved swooping
parachutes I love flying parachutes and
so this demo is like the king of all
demos Allison Wray discovered her
passion for flying through the air and
found a mentor in Jimmy Tranter he's
really kind of a legend in the sport
he's been around forever
25 plus thousand jumps you're the only
woman as part of this team yes the only
woman to jump into the stadium at all
which is pretty big honor for me and a
little badass too it feels like it I
hope so between the four skydivers they
have nearly 50,000 jumps a requirement
to becoming a member of this elite
usually when it comes to jumping out of
a plane it's one thing to hear about it
elbows but another to experience it
[Applause]
we're gonna go now how much faster is it
when you guys are going into the studio
of twice as fast easy for three times
degree of difficulty with this jump
where is it in terms of the world of
skydiving I think it's one of the top
one or two for sure this is technical
and as difficult as it gets this jump is
complex this is where we have to turn in
order to get it steep and dive it down
by the stands but one little detail
makes it perhaps the most difficult most
unique in the world a lot of people will
look at the stadium and say it's a big
wide-open field but immediately as soon
as we add the field goal cables add the
cable cam cables coming from all four
corners and a 50-yard line cable you
actually have to dive small parachutes
through this hole here and it's kind of
like Mission Impossible style
it's a dangerous midair dance for people
working together communicating without
speaking and as far as risk how
important is it to have teamwork it's
everything you got to be able to trust
the people that you're flying with it is
potentially extremely dangerous
it's really like parallel parking a
Ferrari at about 60 miles an hour that's
what it is every single time but I don't
think you can actually do that can you
house but this is and this team has that
ability
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
no they did not let me jump into the
stadium
oh you Dana Jacobson I get the
invigorating part but it looks so
dangerous and you didn't have a helmet
but no helmet on purpose that's I mean
we're tandem here and they are very safe
that's the one thing to remember as far
as all the safety precautions you can
take but obviously there's an inherent
risk and then even more so when you're
talking about that jump into the stadium
was the show there are some people with
the cable have you ever done anything
like that but I did I jumped with the
golden knights of the army about ten
years you know I think two in a lifetime
is enough I loved it I know they find it
invigorating but I think I'm good now
pat tip Dana a big head and you can hear
more of CBS this morning on our podcast
fine extended interviews and podcast
originals on iTunes and Apple's podcast
app you're watching CBS this morning